gentlemen if you want to sell a couple
hundred thousand game boys to little
kids package them with Mario
but if you want to sell millions to
absolutely everyone around the world
packaging with Tetris Tetris it's the
perfect game
it's an extraordinary story involving
lots of different factions from all over
the world all pursuing this incredibly
hot property this game is poetry art and
math all working in magical
synchronicity my character Hank is a
publisher of games who sets him out on
this kind of thing to secure the rights
to Tetris where Russia
there's this one man in the USSR who's
made this thing that everyone wants but
Lexi is the designer he designed the
game because of the laws in Russia at
the time he is denied the right to earn
any money from his game it kind of
becomes the property of the state but
Hank kind of storms into his life
Hank was the first man in Russia to whom
you can talk about computers I'm Gonna
Make You A Millionaire I do not have
right to receive money from my game that
criminal no
it is communism
have you ever negotiated with the
Soviets Mr Hodges do you know what it
feels like to be in a country where
everyone is watching you go home
understood
get the game out of Russia when
everything's chaos there this is an
illegal copy he thinks I stole Tetris
these were true Visionaries that broke
the rules to make the world better
it's an unknown story about a very
well-known game
Hank it's a number of Wars trying to
smuggle the rights of Tetris out of the
USSR one of those blockades being the
maxforce Kevin Maxwell CEO of Marissa
fantastic I would like to buy your
worldwide handheld rights we'll consider
your offer Mr Rogers I haven't made one
yet yes
it's exciting it's drilling it's based
on reality it's just a lot of fun
not so often I can see the movie when I
read the screenplay but this one was
brilliant get me Tetris
it's about companionship and friendship
and that these two Kindred Spirits
capitalists and Communists have kind of
come together my dad put everything on
the line to chase after this game most
people have no idea the drama that the
game went through for it to spread to
the rest of the world I think some
people will feel nostalgic Tetris has
connection with this desire that all
human beings have to create something to
build something to put everything in
order this phrase following blocks it's
about love it doesn't matter where
you're from if you're inspired by what
you're doing there are no barriers
temperatures is a cultural Zeitgeist and
it's quite exciting to think that the
backstory to this phenomenon will
finally get its moment in the sunlight
[Music]